Nos dicen: "El cuadrado debajo representa un
entero", entonces este cuadrado grande representa
un entero, "Expresa el área de color como una
fracción y como un decimal", así que veamos.
Tomamos este entero y lo dividimos en 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 secciones iguales, entonces
cada una de estas filas o cada uno de estos
rectángulos representa 1/10 parte de un entero,
1/10; y veamos, tenemos coloreados 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8 de estos décimos. Ahora, si queremos
representarlo como una fracción podemos decir que
esto es 8/10, y si lo queremos representar como un
decimal podemos decir, ok, tenemos 0 enteros
y 8 décimos, entonces como decimal es 0.8.
Hagamos más de estos ejemplos. Mira esto, aquí
dice "El cuadrado grande debajo representa un
entero. Expresa el área de color como una fracción
y como un decimal". Veamos qué tenemos aquí,
tenemos 10 filas y en cada una de estas filas
tengo 10 cuadrados, entonces tenemos 10 x 10,
que son 100 cuadrados en total; quiere decir
que dividí el entero en 100 partes iguales,
por lo que cada uno de estos cuadrados representa
1 centésimo. Y, bueno, por aquí tenemos coloreados
1, 2, 3 de los 100 centésimos, es decir, tenemos
3 centésimos, por lo tanto, si lo escribimos como
fracción podemos escribirlo como 3/100, 3 / 100,
y como decimal podemos decir, oh, no tengo ningún
entero, no tenemos décimos y tenemos 0.03. Bien,
hagamos un par de ejemplos más. Nos dicen "Expresa
la posición del punto en la recta numérica como
fracción y como decimal". Bien, vamos a pensarlo.
Veamos, aquí tenemos 1/10, aquí tenemos 2/10 y
aquí tenemos 3/10, podemos verlo: tenemos 0, 1/10,
2/10, 3/10, además podemos ver que cada décimo
está a su vez dividido en diez secciones iguales:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 y 10, entonces cada una
de estas marcas representa un centésimo. Observa:
tenemos 1/10 y luego tenemos 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6 centésimos, por lo tanto,
podemos ver que este punto de aquí representa 1
décimo y 6 centésimos. Ahora vamos a escribirlo,
si lo escribimos como decimal tenemos lo
siguiente, tenemos 1 décimo y 6 centésimos;
otra forma de pensar en esto es que aquí tenemos
16 centésimos, podemos contarlos. Recuerda:
cada una de estas marcas representa un centésimo.
Entonces tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 16 centésimos, y la
mayoría de la gente al ver este número no
dirá que es 1 décimo y 6 centésimos, simplemente
dirá que son 16 centésimos. Ahora, ¿cómo podemos
escribir 16 centésimos en forma de fracción?
Lo que hacemos es escribir 16 centésimos,
16 / 100. Hagamos un último ejemplo. Nos dicen:
"El cuadrado grande debajo representa un entero.
Expresa el área de color como una fracción y
como un decimal". Ya hemos visto que el entero
está dividido en 100 cuadritos iguales y que cada
uno de estos cuadrados representa un centésimo,
así que ¿cuántos centésimos están coloreados?
Veamos, aquí tenemos 10 centésimos, 20 centésimos,
30 centésimos, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80 centésimos y 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 centésimos más, 87 centésimos,
entonces como fracción escribimos
87/100. Ahora hay un par de formas
en que podemos considerar esto. Si estamos
familiarizados con ellas podemos decir, ok,
8 décimos es lo mismo que 80 centésimos, entonces
tenemos 8 décimos y 7 centésimos, u 87 centésimos.
Otra forma de verlo es que cada una de estas
filas representa un décimo, tenemos un décimo,
en la siguiente fila dos décimos, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8 décimos, y después tenemos 7 cuadraditos más, 7
centésimos. De cualquier forma que lo pienses, 87
décimos es lo mismo que 8 décimos y 7 centésimos.